The Celestial Message in a Bottle
Imagine for a moment that it’s 40,000 years
in the future in a solar system far, far,
away on a planet thriving with intelligent
life.
Extraterrestrial beings inhabit this place.
Perhaps they look like the cuddly ET, the
blob, ALF, or maybe even like the dreadlocked
beings from Predator; but either way, they
are not human.
An approaching speck in space catches the
beings’ eyes (assuming they have them).
Upon sending a craft to retrieve it, they
find a probe containing a disk.
Using instructions on the disk, they manage
to play it.
What they are about to hear and see are the
sounds and images from an ancient alien civilization
– 1977 Earth.
Flashback about 40 millenia to Cornell University
in Ithaca, New York, Earth in January, 1977.
A brilliant, 43 year old professor named Carl
Sagan is the director of the Laboratory of
Planetary Studies there.
In 1975, he had won the Pulitzer Prize for
his book “The Dragons of Eden,” a dissertation
on the evolution of human intelligence.
He helped shape the field of exobiology, the
study of the potential for life on other planets.
Sagan had also been a key adviser for NASA
dating all the way back to its earliest days.
Working out of the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
in Pasadena, California as a visiting scientist,
he helped design and manage several space
exploration missions, including the Mariner
2’s trip to Venus and Viking one & two’s
trips to Mars.
Also, in the late 1950s, he was involved in
a plan the U.S. had to nuke the moon.
So, when Dr. Sagan received a call to come
to the JPL once again to help NASA, this wasn’t
out of the ordinary.
But this wasn’t an ordinary mission.
In August of 1977, NASA planned on launching
twin unmanned space probes called Voyager
1 & Voyager 2.
The probes’ original mission was to explore
and take pictures of the giants of our solar
system, Jupiter, Saturn, plus all of their
moons.
There was also a hope that if the probe’s
instruments continued to operate, the probes
could do the same with Uranus and Neptune.
Due to “a rare geometric arrangement of
the outer planets” that only happens every
175 years, all four planets were positioned
perfectly so that a probe launched into space
at the proper angle, time, and speed would
be able to pass all of them.
Pluto was never part of the mission due to
it being elsewhere in its orbit and not part
of this geometric arrangement.
The probes were built to last five years,
but there was considerable optimism, that
has since proved founded, that they would
last many years more.
There was also a possible additional mission-
if all went as planned and they were able
to carry it out, they would be the first Earth
crafts to leave our solar system and become
interstellar travelers.
This is what NASA wanted Dr. Sagan for.
In less than nine months, NASA wanted Dr.
Sagan to compile a team and devise a message
in case of contact with an extraterrestrial
civilization outside of our solar system,
a message that needed to convey what life
was like on Earth and be relatively easily
understood by those who receive it.
Now, the chances of the probes ever being
found, detected, or recovered by an extraterrestrial
civilization are incredibly small.
The probes are the size of a small car which
doesn’t even register as a blip in the vastness
of the universe.
For that matter, the Milky Way itself is barely
a blip on that scale.
Additionally, the probes wouldn’t even reach
another planetary system until around 40,000
years into the future.
At that point, Voyager 1 will be nearing Gliese
445 and Voyager 2 will be close to Ross 248.
Nevertheless, it was decided such a message
should be included, just in case.
The decision was made pretty early on that
whatever was sent up there needed to showcase
Earth – the sights and sounds of our home
planet.
It had to be a “cultural Noah’s Ark with
a shelf life of hundreds of millions of years.”
Now, the question was what sights and sounds
exactly?
To answer this question, Dr. Sagan compiled
his team.
Dr. Frank Drake worked with Sagan on the Pioneer
plaque in 1972, which among other things included
the location of Earth, mapping it out via
pulsars.
Ann Druyan was a friend of Sagan’s (later,
his wife) and a young scientific novelist.
She was put in charge of music selection.
Timothy Ferris (at the time, engaged to Druyan)
was a writer for Rolling Stone and would go
on to become “the best scientific journalist
of his generation.”
He helped pick the images that were to be
included.
Jon Lomberg had already been Dr. Sagan’s
artistic collaborator for several years; his
job was to bring color and artistic beauty
to what the interstellar beings would see.
Finally, there was Linda Sagan, Carl’s wife.
She had created the artwork on the Pioneer
plaque and was to help produce this project.
Their first order of business was to figure
out how they were going to convey this message.
The receptacle for this kind of message had
to last for thousands of years and be simple
to play.
Drake suggested the old-school technology
of a phonographic record.
It was rather simple to play and as long as
the physical record itself was protected,
it wouldn’t erode over time.
The etchings on a metallic phonographic record
could last, according to estimations, for
hundreds of millions of years with very little
degradation.
Additionally, they decided to make it a copper
disk coated in gold, further protecting it
from magnetic fields and heat, as well as
placing it in a protective aluminum jacket.
Coupled with an included needle and cartridge,
an alien civilization would be able to play
it.
They also decided to design it to run at 16
2/3 revolutions per minute, as opposed to
the normal 33 1/3 revolutions.
This was done so that they could jam as many
pictures, music, greetings, and information
as they could onto the record.
In order to make sure the aliens knew what
to do with the disk, needle, and cartridge,
symbols were etched in showing how it was
to be used.
For instance, to make sure they know what
speed to rotate the record at, this is etched
in binary arithmetic expressed as a factor
of the fundamental transition of the hydrogen
atom.
In order to demonstrate how the pictures are
to be decoded and viewed, the upper right
portion of the cover shows the analog signal
that is the start of the picture, and in binary
how the first three vertical lines are marked.
They further show how many vertical lines
to a picture.
On the face is also a carefully chosen picture
of the first picture on the record, for calibration
purposes.
Next, and possibly the most arduous task,
was to determine what exactly would be on
this record.
The team wanted the golden record to represent
what life was like on Earth; the sights, sounds,
and feelings we encounter everyday.
After much deliberation, 115 images encoded
in analog form (including a picture of DNA,
human anatomy, Olympic sprinters, an African
hut, and a diagram of vertebrate evolution)
and an audio “track list” with greetings,
sounds, and music were included.
The audio portion began with “Greetings
in 55 languages.”
The first greeting, in English, was from then-Secretary
General of the United Nations Kurt Waldheim.
The rest of the greetings included ones in
Sumerian (“may all be well”), Zulu (“We
greet you, great ones.
We wish you longevity”), Czech (“Dear
Friends, we wish you the best.”), and even
a “whale greeting.”
The next audio section was known as “sounds
of Earth.”
They included things like a baby crying, a
volcano erupting, birds calling, and a train
roaring past.
The last audio section was the music, overseen
by Ann Druyan.
Among the tracks selected for this section
was Beethoven’s Fifth Symphony, a Pygmy
girls’ initiation song from Zaire, Peruvian
panpipes and drums, and “Johnny B. Goode,”
by Chuck Berry.
Noticeably absent was any song from the Beatles.
While the band wanted their hit “Here Comes
the Sun” to be included, they didn’t own
the rights to their songs.
Their publishing company, EMI, did and they
did not allow it to happen.
For everything the team included on this golden
record, probably the most unique – and telling
– inclusion was an EEG brain scan of a young
woman, newly in love.
That woman turned out to be Ann Druyan.
Druyan had planned on going through “a mental
itinerary of the ideas and individuals of
history whose memory I hoped to perpetuate,”
as well as thoughts of her fiancé Tim Ferris
while being connected to the EEG.
But two days before the recording, something
extraordinary happened.
She fell in love with Dr. Carl Sagan.
Days before, they had shared a rather intimate
phone call where they ruminated about life
when they both realized they loved one another.
They hadn’t had a single date nor a kiss
or even a romantic moment before this, but
they decided to marry, despite them both being
in other relationships.
As described by Druyan herself, “It was
a Eureka! moment for both of us—the idea
that we could find the perfect match.
It was a discovery that has been reaffirmed
in countless ways since.”
As for the brain scan, she stated,
Earlier I had asked Carl if those putative
extraterrestrials of a billion years from
now could conceivably interpret the brain
waves of a meditator.
‘Who knows?
A billion years is a long, long time,’ was
his reply.
‘On the chance that it might be possible
why don’t we give it a try?’
Two days after our life-changing phone call,
I entered a laboratory at Bellevue Hospital
in New York City and was hooked up to a computer
that turned all the data from my brain and
heart into sound.
I had a one-hour mental itinerary of the information
I wished to convey.
I began by thinking about the history of Earth
and the life it sustains.
To the best of my abilities I tried to think
something of the history of ideas and human
social organization.
I thought about the predicament that our civilization
finds itself in and about the violence and
poverty that make this planet a hell for so
many of its inhabitants.
Toward the end I permitted myself a personal
statement of what it was like to fall in love.
On August 20, 1977 Voyager 2 lifted off into
space.
Voyager 1 joined its twin 16 days later.
Over the next four years, they explored and
took snapshots of Jupiter and Saturn.
In 1986, Voyager arrived at Uranus.
By 1989, it had passed by Neptune.
Voyager 1 officially entered interstellar
space on August 25, 2012 and as of February
20, 2014, it was 127.25 AU from Earth.
The farthest away of any man-made object.
With perhaps as many as 500 billion galaxies
each with billions of stars (for reference
the Milky Way has about 300 billion), many
of which have planetary objects orbiting them,
it seems likely enough we’re not alone in
the universe.
The Voyager probes will orbit the Milky Way
indefinitely, so you never know.
One of them might encounter an intelligent
alien civilization, maybe even long after
humans have gone the way of the Dodo bird.
And if that day does come when a Voyager Golden
Record is found, first contact may well be
dreadlocked Predator-like extraterrestrials
listening to Chuck Berry’s “Johnny B.
Good.”
While it’s a long-shot, as Sagan himself
noted,
“The spacecraft will be encountered and
the record played only if there are advanced
spacefaring civilizations in interstellar
space.
But the launching of this bottle into the
cosmic ocean says something very hopeful about
life on this planet.”
Bonus Facts:
• In order to allow the recipients to view
certain images in color, three consecutive
images were used in these cases, each representing
red, green, and blue.
In order for them to determine whether they
are calibrating it correctly, a picture of
our sun was included.
Using the pulsar map to locate it, the aliens
should be able to directly compare our sun’s
exact color (which isn’t yellow by the way,
but rather white in the human visual spectrum)
with the image included.
• As one could imagine, despite the cute
love story between Dr. Sagan and Ann Druyan,
there were pretty dire consequences due to
their secret marriage.
They both decided not to reveal it to their
partners until the project was completed.
But when they eventually did, it led to an
eight year legal battle between Carl and Linda,
longer than it took the Voyagers to pass by
Jupiter.
• The team was able to secure a rather valuable
and heartfelt audio message for the probe
from US President Jimmy Carter.
The message said: “This is a present from
a small distant world, a token of our sounds,
our science, our images, our music, our thoughts,
and our feelings.
We are attempting to survive our time so we
may live into yours.
We hope someday, having solved the problems
we face, to join a community of galactic civilizations.
This record represents our hope and our determination,
and our good will in a vast and awesome universe.”